[Musica]
immaginiamo due conti in banca che ora
arrivano da una parte 100 euro
dall'altra un conto in banca di 100mila
euro
la differenza la percepiamo no ci sono
30 in più sono due conti in banca
incomparabili siete d'accordo
se non sei d'accordo a tetti 200 euro i
100mila ritengo io a parte gli scherzi
facciamo una cosa togliamo di euro e
inseriamo
anni ne
sono due intervalli di tempo
mostruosamente diversi imparagonabili
bene arrivo subito al primo messaggio da
portare a casa i tempi umani sono
profondamente diversi dai tempi
geologici
le dinamiche umane avvengono in una
frazione di tempo minuscola rispetto ai
tempi geologici
se noi vogliamo capire le dinamiche
terrestri dobbiamo fare uno switch
mentale cioè passare dalla concezione
del tempo umana a quella geologica ecco
quando sheldon cooper next di bing di
big bang fiori dice next
la gelosia non è una vera scienza
probabilmente
non riusciva a fare questo switch però
lo adoriamo quindi glielo perdoniamo
detto ciò entriamo nel vivo di questo
incontro con con me il riscaldamento
globale attuale è diverso
da quelli del passato
questa è la tesi che che vi presenterò e
ora vi mostrerò gli elementi e i dati
che la supportano
next c'è una fetta di persone che
sostiene tesi di questo genere a il
riscaldamento globale che stiamo vivendo
non ha alcuna relazione con le attività
antropiche
ma è una conseguenza di cicli naturali
oppure a ma in passato ci sono state
tanti ci sono stati tanti i
riscaldamenti globali anche molto più
intensi di quelli di oggi e l'uomo non
ha alcuna relazione quindi è una bufala
quello che dicono in parte è giusto ci
sono sempre state delle variazioni della
temperatura media globale su questo
pianeta con periodi caratterizzati da
temperature anche molto più elevate
rispetto a quelle di oggi è addirittura
superiori ai peggiori scenari previsti
da qua a 100 anni
allora andiamo a vedere queste
variazioni del passato next
il nostro pianeta come sapete a circa 4
miliardi e mezzo di anni noi siamo
riusciti a ricostruire
solamente gli ultimi tra virgolette
solamente 540 milioni di anni circa di
delle variazioni climatiche attraverso
gli studi di ghiacci attraverso lo
studio delle rocce e bene però dire che
di questi dati di questa curva che
vedete vede sull'asse dell'ex cioè il
tempo fino al presente
e le informazioni che sono che sono in
questo grafico sicuramente non hanno la
stessa attendibilità quelle più vecchie
sono meno attendibili più andiamo verso
il presente più sono attendibili
prendiamo in esame un esempio eclatante
che c'è stata nella storia geologica
next 65 milioni di anni fa dove venite
il cerchietto eravamo nelle voce né la
temperatura media globale
a quel tempo era più elevata rispetto a
quella attuale di circa 6 8 gradi
però il tempo impiegato a raggiungere
questo punto qui in alto è stato di
milioni di anni
milioni di anni se contiamo solamente
questo tratto
parliamo di circa 10 milioni però vedete
che la curva cominciata molto prima
probabilmente ci sono voluti 20 30 mila
negli anni ok prendete nota di questa
informazione che ne risulterà utile a
capire le differenze con il
riscaldamento globale attuale ma andiamo
più avanti next
andiamo molto in tempi molto più recenti
e gli ultimi due milioni di anni
i dati ci suggeriscono in maniera
inequivocabile che le variazioni
climatiche negli ultimi 2 milioni di
anni hanno seguito i celebri i celebri
cicli di milano bcc climi milanello
prova i moti millenari probabilmente
alle scuole di state studiando
questi cicli seguono una hanno una
ciclicità
con un periodo di 100.000 anni
soprattutto e secondariamente 41 mila
anni next
ecco come vedete questi cicli sommati
danno proprio la ciclicità che va a
scandire i periodi glaciali e i periodi
interglaciali quindi periodi freddi e i
periodi caldi
andiamo alla prossima se facciamo uno
zoom negli ultimi 800 mila anni
possiamo contare 8 grossi cicli next
questa è un giusto per per ricalcare per
farla un po più smooth next possiamo
vedere che ci sono 8 periodi che
corrispondono a 8 periodi interglaciali
questi caldi e 8 glaciali
non a caso per chi come vi ho detto c'è
una ciclista una ciclicità
principale di 100.000 anni
da quel momento poi le temperature da da
circa 20 mila anni quindi siamo intorno
siamo in questa parte del grafico che
cosa succede
l'ultimo periodo glaciale si è
verificato intorno ai 20mila anni
20 mila anni fa da quel momento le
temperature hanno ricominciato a
risalire entrando intorno ai 10 11 12
mila anni fa in una nuova fase
interglaciale quindi calda che si chiama
holocene gli ultimi 10.000 anni il clima
è stato complessivamente
stabile con variazioni relativamente
limitate che hanno permesso alla civiltà
umana di evolversi molto rapidamente
grazie alle condizioni ottimali per lo
sviluppo dell'agricoltura
dell'allevamento
non a caso è stato definito ottimo
climatico dell'olocene
l'aspetto interessante che in questo
periodo la concentrazione di co2 next in
atmosfera e variata next tra 190 e
290 ppm parti per milione c'è la
variazione c'è stata ma è stata
contenuta in questo range
nella parte finale del grafico vedere
dove c'è la stellina né
li è evidente che la concentrazione di
co2 in atmosfera sia schizzata in alto
improvvisamente
raggiungendo nel 2020 valori intorno al
quattrocento 10420 ppm
ripetiamolo nell'ultimo secolo siamo
passati da 290 300 ppm a 410 420
questo negli ultimi 800 mila anni non
era mai successo
mai successo bene gli ho fatto due
orecchie così per farvi capire i tempi
lunghi lunghissimi delle variazioni
climatiche del passato ora spero che ce
l'abbiamo in testa il riscaldamento
globale attuale sta variando invece alla
scala dei decenni al massimo dei secoli
ma soprattutto dei decenni
e praticamente è la stessa differenza
che c'era tra i conti in banca 100 100
mila enorme e la stessa differenza
le variazioni attuali di cui tanto si
parla
possono essere
associate
ai cie
scusate le variazioni attuali di cui
tanto si parla non possono essere
associate ai cicli naturali del pianeta
che come abbiamo visto hanno periodi
mostruosamente più grandi ecco abbiamo
parlato di co2
gas serra
se ne sente parlare tanto ormai
decarbonizzazione carbonio ecco il
carbonio e il protagonista
della storia del film se non abbiamo
presente le vicende del protagonista
probabilmente la storia del film ci
sfugge per capire il riscaldamento
globale è fondamentale capire come si
muove questo carbonio dove sta
quanto viene emesso dalla natura quanto
viene messo da noi ecco con gioco mi
capita spesso di sentire no ma
l'emissione di gas serra da parte
dell'uomo sono solamente una
piccolissima percentuale rispetto a
quelle naturali quindi il riscaldamento
globale
e naturale
sì non sia ben presente next il ciclo
del carbonio sul pianeta terra e ben
difficilmente si avranno gli strumenti e
le informazioni per capire davvero il
rischio il riscaldamento globale di oggi
bene cerchiamo di capirlo al volo
ok è una cosa estremamente complessa io
chiaramente cercherò di sintetizzare di
semplificarla per per darvi un input che
poi spero che questi input porti magari
qualcuno di voi a studiare come
giustamente saggiamente diceva il prof
la conoscenza è fondamentale
bene sistema che nell'intero sistema
terra su tutta la terra ci siano
1,85 miliardi
di peda g che era una parolaccia da una
cosa fu cosa no fetta g equivale a 1.000
miliardi di kg per capire bene questo
ciclo possiamo immaginare che le riserve
di carbonio sul nostro pianeta si
distribuiscono in dei serbatoi
giganteschi chiamati pool chiamiamo le
piscine ok prendiamo i quattro serbatoi
principali la crosta terrestre l'oceano
la biosfera e l'atmosfera nella crosta
ci sono 100 milioni di peda g negli
oceani 38 mila
di cui circa 1000 pendant g nella parte
più superficiale dell'oceano nella
biosfera ce ne sono 2060 nell'atmosfera
750li pendant g ricordatevi questo
numeretto perché è qui che si gioca la
partita
del riscaldamento globale
queste quattro precipi cine di carbonio
comunicano tra loro si scambiano
carbonio naturalmente attraverso dei
meccanismi naturali che noi chiamiamo
flussi ok
le stime più recenti indicano che le
piante rimuovono dall'atmosfera
assorbono all'atmosfera la co2
dall'atmosfera in una quantità pari a
120 next 120 programmi all'anno e ne
restituiscono circa 58 dalla
respirazione delle piante e 59 dalla
composizione dei terreni la co2
rilasciata nell'atmosfera come vedete
più o meno corrisponde alla stessa
quantità di carbonio che assorbe un
equilibrio tanto eccezionale quanto
sottile e ora capiremo perché
l'altro esempio next di flusso e quello
tra oceano e atmosfera l'oceano ogni
anno assorbe circa il 92 peta g
dall'atmosfera mentre ne rilascia
novanta come vedete anche in questo caso
l'equilibrio e incredibile nota
interessante con l'aumento della
temperatura media globale l'oceano
diminuisce la capacità di assorbire co2
più fa caldo e meno riesce a toglierla
dall'atmosfera che succede che la co2 in
atmosfera comincerà a stagnare
ok si stagna aumenta la temperatura
media gli oceani praticamente si
indeboliscono sempre più è una sorta di
reazione a catena
questo si intende quando si parla di
effetti irreversibili
questo è un esempio
next
spessissimo sento dire i vulcani ai
vulcani sono loro che emettono più di
tutti
in realtà in media ogni anno i vulcani
di tutto il mondo emettono circa
0,1 d'età grammi di carbonio che è un
centesimo dell'anidride carbonica
prodotta dalle attività umane una
singola eruzione è chiaro e mette tanto
ma noi il conto lo dobbiamo fare a
livello globale o fare una media e la
media ci dice che la quantità è
relativamente piccola
questo ciclo che ho provato a
sintetizzare ea semplificare brutalmente
è stato in equilibrio
per diversi milioni di anni con le sue
variazioni ma in equilibrio mantenendo
la concentrazione di co2 nell'atmosfera
più o meno costante nel tempo
l'atmosfera
naturalmente può gestire
750 peta grammi di carbonio rimanendo in
equilibrio
ecco se immaginiamo l'atmosfera
come una bottiglia di vino giustamente
tutti vi starete chiedendo ma questo si
deve imbragare
immaginiamo che questa sia l'atmosfera è
in equilibrio
succede qualcosa stalla da almeno dieci
minuti no perfetto
quindi non ci sono problemi ma se
prendiamo
un bicchierino
cecchetto che contiene 10 ml di vino e
dover siamo nella bottiglia
mi sembra evidente che c'è un problema
l'equilibrio si è rotto
banale
il cicchetto rappresenta le nostre
attività e non a caso ho scelto un
cicchetto da 10 ml perché noi next
ogni anno e mettiamo circa 8 10 peta
grammi di carbonio
che
naturalmente non sarebbero state emesse
perché perché il sistema terra nella sua
magia in gran parte le aveva stoccate
nelle rocce nei giacimenti di carbone
petrolio gas e sarebbero rimaste lì per
chissà quanti milioni di anni e se anche
fossero fuoriuscite lo avrebbero fatto
gradualmente nei tempi geologici
no non umani noi le abbiamo tirati fuori
praticate con in un battito di ciglia
geologico ecco la nostra quantità di co2
seppur piccola va a destabilizzare
l'equilibrio naturale è questo il
problema
questa minima parte perché una minima
parte rispetto a quelle naturale di 8 10
pendant g
vanno a ristagnare in atmosfera
conseguenza effetto serra aumenta
conseguenza della conseguenza la
temperatura media globale aumenta quindi
dobbiamo capire che noi siamo parte di
questo ciclo è che le nostre azioni
destabilizzano quel delicatissimo e
sottilissimo equilibrio naturale
se vogliamo davvero combattere il
riscaldamento globale
dobbiamo capirlo
anche chi non è esperto
credo che tutto parta dalla conoscenza
perché la conoscenza ti dà modo di
essere consapevole e la consapevolezza
ti dà modo di agire
grazie
[Applauso]